ya lo welcome to a new video um yeah
this was will be a somewhat different
video as I won't do a blitz game or our
rapid game with live commentary but
instead i'll briefly show a game that I
played yesterday and it's um a
tournament game with the classical time
control um well classical the outlets of
food was it was a Fisher time control 90
minutes form for 40 moves and additional
30 minutes i'll move 40 plus 30 seconds
some increment / move from from with one
so it's somewhat yeah me sometimes
caught the yeah the quick quick fish on
time control with increment yeah this
this was some this game was played on in
the german on club cap event so it sound
it's a cup tournament on with them with
the teams um on for boards so we've got
four games I'm going simultaneously and
um yeah I'm one of the four boards
actually I'm bought one for my club so I
always some get them yeah well almost
always get the best players of the
opposing teams and this time we play
dumb the the wounded german bundesliga
first league team of Zululand and there
was some put up a pretty strong team in
the club he wins and the cup events um
so I got to play grandma some German
Grand Master they don't a use their own
yeah that that show top players that
they have in the team there for yeah
more close to I think the half half of
the of the dead soon as national team in
the club but usually they only play with
German players and then the cap zone
well I get to play a Michele Hoffman
he's a pretty good grandmaster
about 2,500 and I also got the black
pieces on not the easiest task around
but while I know I'm pretty good i
played them well together with him Adam
to another team cell um yeah so I pretty
much knew what to expect them and well
when you play black against him you yeah
you don't know what to expect actually
because he plays all loose all possible
mainstream move so to say efore d4c 493
basically everything that there isn't he
also plays the main lines and also in
addition he also knows them well so it's
a pretty good theoretical plan ok so I
didn't do any specific preparation and
yeah let's let's have a look at the game
he played the c4 um and I took a five
minute to think here after c4 because
well I didn't prepare anything specific
and I was trying to think of something
that he probably doesn't know too well
and also couldn't expect from me so I at
the end I chose them may be somewhat
yeah questionable line we'll see what's
coming up but it's a bit mysterious in a
way ok I played c5 he went night of 3
which is the most aggressive move here
knight c6 93 yeah now I'm it's an
interesting point here from blacks point
of view I played here the move on g6
which sometimes is considered somewhat
dubious but yeah there have been a
couple of games recently environment a
strong players on and they played g6
that will nevertheless end they played a
somewhat rare idea which are also used
in the game which will somehow should be
playable for black but yeah we'll see in
the game um of course
I'm white here has different options g6
um in a way prevents d for now um let's
have a quick look if white plays d form
which is often played of course from
structural point of view here CD form 94
Bishop g7 and now the problem is that
the knight on d4 simply yeah simply
attacked and needs to move again wyd
simply lacks the time to conveniently
cover this night with Bishop e3 for
instance if the movie for andy sixx
would have been inserted let's say black
would play d 6 which would be of course
inferior but just just to show before
Bishop g7 then white could easily
protect the night with Bishop e3 and we
would get a standard standard position
here in this particular instance though
after Bishop g7 the night has to move
again and while the best square
relatively speaking sse2 and now black
actually has a very good option
capturing on c3b takes c3 and queen a 5
which is considered yeah it's not a lot
not really clear verdict by by analysts
here black is already somewhat better or
just equal law but while it's nothing
that why should really am go for Saudi
force not not really good here and the
other main alternative he of courses for
y2 to just play g3 and go for a somewhat
standard position here in symmetrical
English um in this position on black has
some huge choice he could go for well
say e6 which was um Fischer's favorite
move or e 5 which is possible also d 6
or 9 f 6 of course complete sim complete
symmetry also possible yeah this was
possible but well in general
this whole way of playing is considered
from White's point of view somewhat yeah
it's not very aggressive what needs to
need to um well play somewhat more
directly here to get something he can
play this of course but it's not it's
not really aiming for a huge opening
advantage okay but the main objection to
the move g6 otherwise it would be a
great move it's a movie III here and he
also played this Zoe as I said he gnosis
gnosis openings the idea here is off III
to play quick deform and even d4 d5
possibly to attack the Sun I don't see
six which which has been developed there
somewhat yeah prematurely this that's
this what white is trying to prove for
instance if black black players which
would Bishop g7 deform then on the next
move this night will get kicked with d5
and it needs to retreat back to be aid
go to a five which is not a great square
or maybe go to e5 which is also not too
great so this is most likely am just
better for wired so black plays Knight
f6 I also played this deform and now I'm
black is ready after CDE dd5 to
transpose into yeah somewhat
surprisingly into a position that could
also have been reached on from before
opening the caro-kann this is just a
position from the panel variation of the
caro-kann i could i can quickly show how
it is reached after you form it's always
funny what kind of trans positions are
possible this is this is the e4 way to
reach this
no g6 exactly the same position and in
the game we had exactly the same yeah
okay I'm now white plate seat XD 59 txt
5 this is um yeah it's very much agree
that this is the best way to play for
wine and queen bee three um yeah and now
it's on the first yeah interesting point
here now the the main move here for four
black or at least the moved edison has
been played most often as to capture on
t3d five is of course just hanging so
neck needs to move this night or just do
something about this and benign TX III
actually as answered not with the
recapture but with a strong move Bishop
c4 it's a funny funny idea it just the
text f7 and black simply has no decent
square for the snide on that same we try
to save them light then white could
simply capture here and get back the
piece so I cannot I cannot really am
here secure this piece somehow the only
diff decent options here IE six or my 95
back so let's check check this quickly
after e6 can beat xe3 Bishop g7 bishop a
3 this is some 11 problem here which is
really caused by this move Bishop c4
which provoked like to play e6 so now we
cannot cancel and let's say we should
have aid exchange and castles and why it
is just somewhat better here some slide
and very slight advantage and very
comfortable position at the bishop on CA
deserve not easily develop TN black also
needs some time to organize
species here came to g7 and yeah why
does of course somewhat better the
alternative here which is played more
softness 95 white captures and then he
six somewhat funny funny move sequence
so wyd now needs to take on c6 otherwise
d4 would just be lost and we get a
position of this this kind of this kind
of position where black has got the
bishop pair but the bishop CA does not
really great iam likes dream is to
transfer this bishop to d5 if you would
manage this he would put ever really
nice position but it's not easy to do
this is also considered somewhat better
for white and this is this kind of
variations on other reason I'm for the
move from 33 chizek g6 having a bad
reputation it says exactly this um this
move sequence here yeah but now we get
to the point what I actually played I
played e6 here which is yeah um not a
new move but it has been tried recently
um by three year good players so somehow
this Muslim came to my attention and I
decided to give this a go here actually
I decided on move 12 to go for this
position because it was very likely that
we reached this after c4 c5 um yeah now
that I have from looked yeah check this
a little bit little bit deeper after the
game i don't think i would actually
repeat this but well it was a thought of
playing the slide only at the bart this
line only at the bottom okay play Bishop
bum to be five here and there have been
as i mentioned a couple of games in this
line and it's
sometimes the little details are I
interesting the first game that was
played on a high level was between
kashima dumb um azerbaijan a theory
grandmaster and took part of Sao to pull
off when for this position as black and
gossamer played Bishop g5 here which
also looks critical to me to be honest
topalov not answered with f6 maybe maybe
black has something else here I'm not
sure during the game when we actually
had this position and he thought form I
don't know five minutes or something I
was briefly thinking after Bishop g5
maybe black can also play other moves to
Queen a five or queen bee six or
something on f6 is really an ugly moose
well let's check quickly the game Bishop
t 2 g 7 Bishop d3 castles castles Nazi
seven rook fe1 this was gushing off
topalov and yeah it's pretty obvious
that white has an advantage here because
it's just just an ugly set up with f6
and e 66 points weekend um white has a
very nice active development and he also
got tech going with H for later which is
also inviting idea so gosh you've got a
pretty good position here against top
olive but the funny thing is a couple of
month later this game was played in 2010
gashi moth got the black pieces against
chrome nakina think it was a rapid event
so not too much not a very important
game but joshimath then played exactly
this line is black so despite the
earlier experience against a part of
got a nice position he decided to play
this as black so maybe he yeah he looked
at this line and considered it yeah at
least worth a try so it shouldn't be he
shouldn't be too awful I'm also and this
was actually the game which brought this
whole line to my attention um the e6
line here was also played by the world
champion by Anand in his game against
vallejo the Spanish Grand Master but
vallejo didn't really play anything
critical I think just tried to play the
simplest possible he took on d5 we
should be five we should be 1783 and
this pretty much invites the Queen trade
here and they played this kind of
position which at the end aren't
actually one with black should be a well
it should be a draw what it's an equal
position but at the end um and even
managed to squeeze out a win here oh
this was not really a triad refutation
what if you ask me Bishop g5 looks like
the critical move to me ok but give my
opponent play Bishop b5 I'm the idea
heum we should be five vessel is
sometimes just to capture on c6 and then
try to play against the somewhat weak
porn um we should be a g7 which is very
logical both the side castles and this
is actually following the game Kramnik
against kashima of course we were not
aware of this I actually had only knew
this an art game and what I just thought
if an art can play this line and be okay
then okay it shouldn't be completely
terrible for black so um which is
actually very yeah very good fallback
option sometimes if you don't know
exactly what
what is played in a certain position or
unsure but you have some some print some
recollection that it was played by a
really strong player like like a world
champion or challenger photo title or
something then it can be pretty sure
that at least that it's at least a
decent move yeah kramnik here in this
position here's why to move after black
castles a chronic played rugby one looks
um yeah very very sensible to me just
covered you for um not quite sure what I
what I would answer them I also didn't
look the game up I'm not sure what gashi
mouth played actually but okay let's get
back to to to my game he took on c6 here
which is not unusual in this kind of
structure to UM yet we can hear the the
palm position and maybe try to play
against the pawn on c6 or organon I to
c5 this would be would be typical in
kinds of maneuvers what but I think this
is actually somewhat premature here we
will see in the game I think it's still
um I think equal equal position but it
considerably helps me I think I played
rookie one which also could be
questioned if you look at the game
continuation okay rook rook e1 I played
and I a queen to be six this year seemed
very logical to me as I think I may be
just threatening to to exchange on b3
and this oh yeah damage pawn structure
should be a problem for white so I
thought he needs to react somehow and he
played Quincy to which I expected so
relatively speaking most active moves
and I also expected the next couple of
of moves but yeah it gets really crazy
at dinner in a very short amount of time
here and I've learned that before I do
play Queenie for yeah this is the
sharpest move and I absolutely expected
it because everything else is just too
passive white could play Queen D 1 but
when the soul on queen bee three to see
to 2d one doesn't make a very active
impression i can just play a normal
strengthening move here let's say Bishop
basics or crew create or something and I
think it should be it should be about
equal okay he went to known to e form
and of course this some has a simple
idea to to switch the Queen over to h4
bishop h 6 95 and made on h7 and in an
ideal world from white point of view one
this would happen but I have a pretty
strong move him and he I think he didn't
really take this into account i can play
me five now and it's it's it's an easy
to miss move from its in a way because
why does some yeah hanson rook only one
knight on f3 queen and everything on d5
and you always try to yeah make the
bishop on CH the bad piece so you don't
really expect the e porn to move but of
course and yeah black can play this
because Bishop f5 is the idea here with
the tempo and then night c2 and while
I'm just flopping the rooks on you 1 and
a 1 um so pure lead on tactical
justification for the smooth actually
the next move is played it played this
relatively quickly and I also thought it
would be here basically the only move it
shows that we both
didn't calculate to do too well okay it
took only five he's got a very decent
alternative yet maybe the money should
play 9 a-4 the reason for this becomes
obvious in the game if you look at the
game and in this position I need to play
Queen B 5 if I would go back to c7 for
instance he could take on e5 and before
it's just hanging so I need to go to 2
square where I actually attack this
night and now white can can take on e5
which is somewhat similar to the game
the point is after Bishop f5 Queen h4 we
get to the game position and I cannot
really take on a form well I can but
it's it's not good place bishop d to a
58 or a three and he will get this piece
back within with an advantage right has
got an extra pawn it's still playable
for black young it's not completely
terrible and I've got two bishops and
some may be some counter play against e5
possibly this Bishop can go to d5 it's
playable and but not not something I
would have gone from most likely we
would have got the game position but you
would avoid something let's let's look
at the game first d5 Bishop f5 of course
logical what else Queen h4 night see two
very logical and now we played an eye to
a form and now if you if I play Queen B
5 know which I did we would have gotten
the same position in the line before
just with the different move order the
important point is here I play Queen me
five but I should have played Quincy 7am
and this would have been much better
what happens now Bishop age 6
and then for instance I can take on age
six Queen takes I take the rook in the
corner he came captures c6f 6re f6 and
then for instance rookie one is just a
simple line there are some some
alternatives of course Queenie three and
this position is yeah slightly flatten
slightly better for black I think I've
got an extra exchange but why just got a
porn and he's got nice positions for his
nights the five nights got a nice
position and the other one my top to c5
and I'm not sure I check this also
briefly with the computer and he gives
this s and now 0.2 or something for
black so it's not not serious maybe it's
just equal I wouldn't be terribly afraid
to have this position as wide as well
but I should have gone for the second
and try to play for a win here um ok so
on I day for I played Queen B 5 I should
have gone Quincy seven but just some
some lines that are possibly it's a
terribly complicated position we both
actually assumed in the game that night
f1 needs to be played in order to
protect be to the computer actually
showed that he could also play on Fisher
page six amazing name and it leads to a
couple of really exciting lines um maybe
this is this is nothing worse than 9 a-4
but but it's impossible almost to
calculate in the game the main line here
would be to take on a one takes on g7
King takes I need to recapture here
otherwise he would play Bishop f6 and
Queen h6 and and I'm just done I'm just
gone and now the
he move 94 this is very important
because white now threatens Bishop takes
f5 check GTX f5 Queen g5 with perpetual
check and might continue Bishop e6 rook
takes a one route 88 d for us hanging
now so I capture here I covers this c5
takes takes Queen e7 check takes takes
Queen e6 King g7 and this is maybe
slightly better for black but now we all
move 25 and well this is an alternative
that starts with Bishop h6 year for four
white and black also can play takes on
be too Queen takes be too I could also
capture on only one so this is
completely impractical to to calculate
this for instance one line if I take on
you one oops on you one this is really
crazy Ruby one Queen B to Bishop g7 King
Basenji 794 still playing but this trick
to take on f5 and give the perpetual of
course black can always for instance in
this position I can just capture c3 and
it's a draw it's just a question if
black can try to play for a win here we
should be three for instance it's a
funny line Queen f6 check kingi 896
threatening 97 checkmate so I need to UM
yeah make some um some square here for
the king e seven king edge devil and
night retreats and now why does somehow
covering other important things here the
nuts cover each other look a c8 and now
I'm really am
an amazing line of course found by the
computer we didn't see even the first
tools or so about office at the H form
Roxy three and now unbelievably e6 which
which threatens e7 or to e7 and also
threatened c3 the Queen and night just
the check the rook on c3 so for instance
Roxy too and now e seven Queen takes f6
also all only moves check King g7 and
now for instance ruby three white can
even way to move here Bishop f5 takes
takes rook a three and yeah this might
be a shade better for black but well
it's maybe just a draw but of course
this is a 15 move deep line here so it's
completely unrealistic to to to
calculate this um I'm not quite sure
what what I actually saw in the game
here but I was pretty sure that that he
needed to play and night a four and he
he do he did so um okay but while I
played a queen to be five I should have
done to c7 as mentioned before Queen B 5
um Bishop h6 ya know I took on it and a
one I also could have taken on e one
actually and then he recaptures bouquet
e8 takes takes something like this this
what's also possible and I don't know I
don't know how to evaluate this position
it so I think white has some pretty
decent compensation here
he can just play oh sorry you can just
play em some normal move see in here it
doesn't need to be M to play something
spectacular can play for long-term
compensation also with the squares on c5
for the night yeah it would have been
possible i but I've found it much more
logical to capture on a one to get the
rook back in the corner as here needs to
recapture and a couple of moves what I
didn't really am evaluate correctly is
the position that has reached a couple
of moves later he captured on g7 first
here King takes 94 and now we also see
them the idea here of the perpetual
check coming up for instance if i go to
d5 here then then he could just go for
this petrol and just a draw but ok i
went to d3 to avoid the immediate draw i
consider to consider my position to be a
very good here but i don't i didn't
evaluate this correctly um he played an
i2c 59 and in order to to avoid the draw
i need to play Queen d2 this covers the
g5 square where the Queen would need to
give a check widescreen to give the
perpetual after night takes f5 so it
took on a one route 88 and I calculated
this position before and I thought I
would be much better here as I am avoid
I'm the immediate perpetual check and I
thought I should be better because well
i got the rukon the aid in play and also
would see in cm now he takes on
f5 heats to give the check here kingi
aid and I thought well I thought about
this position and I didn't see really
how I should strengthen strength
strengthen the position here because I'm
threatening I made here on d1 quindi one
rookie one and just check made so
Francis am he cannot let H form and we
cannot capture yeah because of after of
the matey and you won so after h4 group
d 5 I was thinking well this should be
you should be really better for me but
when we actually reached the position
and I was looking a little bit deeper I
got more and more pessimistic about the
position and we can we can look at this
he played before now which I didn't
really am take into account to be honest
well a couple fools before when we reach
it it was obvious that you should play
this okay and now it's it's not so easy
for black to UM to really am make
progress here I always need to attend to
this on Queen g5 perpetual idea so I
cannot move the Queen without allowing
the perpetual and while the only move
that I seriously considered besides the
one that I played a caption of Milan
it's rookie age this is also fairly
logical to a tacky five and then i
calculated e6 takes takes rook t7 i need
to because on g7 is just a mid threat
and have no other way to cover it um and
Queen f5 and I really disliked this
position because my king is wide open
here and he's already got two pawns um
and well I was um I was a bit a bit
skeptical about my chances iam I should
have I think calculated a bit further I
didn't have so much time but I think
maybe I should have looked somewhat her
I didn't really appreciate the move
Queen d5 I was just thinking okay I can
always give a check oops give a check
here and maybe retreat the Knight to g5
for instance odd for something but in
fact after this year aged six black is
just better Rukia fade and in this
position I'm threatening rook g7 just
winning because f3 is then hanging um
black is better here maybe I should have
gone for this but I didn't really take
this move 25 into account properly for
instance if I play this year which i
looked at briefly then just 95 and it's
it's very unclear for instance if i give
this check here he can even play king hm
king edge too because on f 7 h-7 as a
main threat and while this the
combination of night and and queen is
notoriously dangerous so yeah yeah I
wasn't I wasn't completely sure but at
the end with the clock ticking down
after before I just decided that the
draw is not too bad in this game so I
recap I capture just on before and now
what needs to give the perpetual of
course so we repeated two times and then
decided to
yeah to agree to a draw um yeah it was
really a really complicated game and it
also shows that if you need to calculate
lots of complicated variation that the
computer afterwards will show that you
only saw yeah only saw I'm sorry small
percentage of the lines um interesting
one interesting point really was here
only 15 we're night a form actually
would have would have forced the game
continuation which was quite okay for
white it was it wasn't intended of
course but it was yeah maybe maybe
compensation for the for the exchange
I'm very complicated of course and what
he should do that I think after Queen c7
which was really the the main I think
chance that i missed here in this game
this kind of position I think I can I
can play and play on a bit and try to
try to win it um one key difference to
to the gamer so that I still have two
points at least at the cover for my king
and now the line on that I am the SH
that I showed this kind of line um White
has two points i just got h7 left i'm
also in addition um before I forget this
I am i just showed cringey form but
actually why it could could exchange
here just to show this quickly I need to
take with them the pawn of course
otherwise 97
94 rookie for rookie one takes this kind
of position white is called upon upon
for the exchange and this is maybe just
very slightly better for black I
actually had a check this quickly with
the computer and you actually give this
as equal which I find somewhat
surprising I think black should still be
better because if someone is doing
something here then it's black with the
rooks trying to trying to win another
pawn or maybe somehow get this night
away from before and try to invade on
the second rank so black should be
somewhat better White has a decent
drawing chances of course but just equal
I don't I don't buy it but this is maybe
the objectively best way to play for
wide if i would have gone rook e8 which
of course I should have done but I maybe
I got some yeah i was somewhat maybe
somewhat afraid about this position
because i really hated to have somewhat
open king here but i also I really
underestimated this year I thought okay
wyd would just give a check and and play
on here but it's not that easy actually
yeah okay um I think him we are we're
through here and did this video has
gotten much longer than I expected yeah
I hope you like the game and i will also
on the description add a quick p GN yeah
notation here that you could can look up
the game or maybe replay it on a board
yeah thanks for watching and see you
soon with the couple of more blitz or
rabbit videos this was somewhat of a
half a special a special video yeah
thanks and bye